welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Hector Navarro and this is a breakdown
of the official final trailer for Blue
Beetle coming to theaters August 18th
before we jump into all the scaraby
goodness I want to remind you that new
rockstars is now three channels this
main channel for Easter egg breakdowns
the Deep dive for special film analyzes
from your favorite in mind Mr Eric Voss
and the break room where you can find
our secret Invasion after show inside
Marvel hey I'm on that too cool
subscribe to all three and support our
network with a scroll inspired shirt
from nerdriot.shop unless you yourself
are a scroll in which case you should
still get one to throw people off your
Trail let's get started here we go
okay
I want to play let's do this
[Music]
you got a force it to come out what do
you you're a genius I know like what I
say
[Music]
in the opening of the trailer we see
Hiro Jaime Reyes played by sholo
mariduenya his uncle Rudy played by the
legend George Lopez and Jenny cord Our
Hero's potential love interest played by
Brazilian actress Bruno marchesini Jenny
being related to the villain of the
movie Victoria cord Jaime is rocking
some color appropriate attire and trying
to get himself to fly as one would if
they learned they were bonded to an
alien super suit we can also see a
beetle-shaped statue on the railing
nearby got us around this movie and all
kinds of beetles after some inspiration
from Theo Rudy rocking what is probably
a Virgin Mary tattoo we get to see an
extremely cool slow-motion Blue Beetle
activation and then we cut two
oh did you know what was going to happen
to my brother when you stalk him with
this world destroying thing
it's called the Scarab
I had no idea it would activate it has
to choose you
so how do we get it to unchoose me
who said that systems
[Applause]
one day earlier which gives us some idea
how much time might pass for this
superhero origin story we may see Jaime
have to become the Blue Beetle fight for
his family in a matter of days then
another shot of the Sci-Fi Advanced
looking Palmyra City skyline with some
missable details you might have missed
ace chemicals on the left an ad for ax
body spray saying power up with blue so
look out for that real world product
placement maybe an ad for a Ramen Temple
opening soon Alex Corp building that
doesn't quite get to finish spelling out
its letters which technically gives us
our first mention of Lex Luthor in this
new DC Universe franchise cool new
Superman actor David Karen sweat is
probably gonna have to deal with that
guy then cord Plaza and all its purple
Glory a little boat advertising PC
coffee maybe a Ford truck ad so look out
for that real world product placement
probably coming soon and some signage
for a business called Yogi yoga which I
feel like some characters in this movie
might benefit from after dealing with
all this trauma next shot is the inside
of cord Plaza with some more miscible
details like images of the movie's
villain Victoria cord played by Speed
Racer's mom Susan Sarandon surrounded by
kids with the word humanitarian above
them reminder that just like in our
world a Billionaire's philanthropy work
is usually used to cover up the more
shady stuff they're doing too real plus
we also see some examples of chord Tech
like their version of a VR headset or a
Google Glass type of product cord may be
the dcu's version of Apple but you know
evil or I should say more evil we then
see a great close-up of the Scarab as
Jenny tells us it's called hooked up to
what's probably a bunch of chord
equipment as they are trying to study
the alien text capabilities Theo Rudy
Sports an EMC chain around his neck
which knowing his anti-fascist ideology
May stand for everything must change
which is dope
protection
[Music]
[Applause]
like we've seen before we get to
re-experience the glory that is the
Scarab suiting Jaime up for the first
time and once that cheeky alien Tech
voice kicks in we learned that she's got
a real personality too
overreacting
posts overreacting classic that's great
one other thing we want to make sure to
point out is the brilliant little sound
of Amazement that Jaime lets out while
his suit is slicing through the city bus
it's just a great acting choice or
writing choice or whoever's Choice it
was deserves all the praise because it's
hilarious
also right after this moment we get a
shot of a little brown kid in the bus
looking up to see the superhero and
we're sure this moment was very
purposeful reminding us how little we've
seen Latino superhero main characters
and big projects like this and how much
Jaime Reyes and his story means to us
all thank you to better help for
sponsoring this video here at new
rockstars we like to figure out what
makes movies work go frame by frame to
figure out what's really going on but
when we need Insight on what's going on
with ourselves we use Better Health
betterhelp is the world's largest
therapy service and it's 100 online with
better help you can tap into a network
of over 30 000 license and experienced
therapists who can help you with a wide
range of issues to get started just
answer a few questions about what you're
looking for from therapy and what your
preferences are betterhelp will then
match you with a therapist from their
Network that's right for you after that
talk to your therapist however you feel
comfortable whether it's via text chat
phone or video call you can message your
therap at any time and schedule live
sessions when it's convenient for you if
your therapist isn't the right fit for
any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge
betterhelp gives you the same level of
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom picked for you
more scheduling flexibility and at a
more affordable price get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com new
rockstars that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com Slash new
rockstars for 10 off your first month of
therapy next up we're going to point to
this really cool military looking Arctic
installation probably built by cord
Industries complete with their own
version of the Las Vegas eye orb Suite
this actually brings us to a great shot
with some folks you may recognize Susan
Sarandon as Victoria cord is in the
middle of course looking super cool in
her Arctic Gear with two great actors
flanking her on either side on screen
left we've got Raul Max Trujillo we saw
earlier in the trailer attending some
fancy schmancy party as Conrad karapaks
aka the indestructible man here rocking
a really badass looking Poncho probably
covering up some cool Tech of his own
check out his hand and on screen right
we've got Harvey Guillen who you may
know as Guillermo from the what we do in
the shadows series and who you may have
heard as the voice of perrito in Puss in
Boots the last wish the best movie of
last year here playing Dr Sanchez a
scientist working with Victoria court
and Court Industries himself rocking a
very cozy looking jacket and hat we have
a feeling that he may be the type of
scientist character who realizes the
error of his ways and turns on the bad
guys because how can you ask audiences
to root against Harvey Guillen he's a
damn international treasure
foreign
[Music]
packs we get to see a fierce battle
between the villain and our hero Blue
Beetle but you may have missed some of
the detailing of the bad guy's armored
suit it looks like we've got at least
two versions of karapaks with one
looking a bit more like an exoskeleton
that's the one picking on Jaime as he
yells you got the wrong guy I'm a nobody
I swear and another shot of a more fully
armored Terra packs may be reaching his
final form of the indestructible man we
think taking place after that pretty
gnarly shot of wires and cables
inserting themselves into karapak's arm
and body we think we're gonna get cord
siphoning some of the scarab's power
into this armor and giving us a red
beetle version of the good guy blue
beetles I have an Arsenal at my disposal
anything please
whatever you can imagine
I can create yeah that's more like it
and after a kick-ass line from the
Scarab itself
we see a blink and you'll miss it detail
glowing near the blue beetles Weaponry
symbols that may be the alien reaches
language also cleverly looking
reminiscent of Earth Egyptian
hieroglyphics tying in some of that
sci-fi history of the reach with the DC
universe's own fictional Egyptian
history of which there is a connection
in the comics
[Music]
I love you feel for your family
you rock my family that's what makes me
strong
oh I forgot how bad it looks
Target the family
sorry my mom
then after a fantastic tagline telling
us he's a superhero whether he liked it
or not we get to see another example of
that initial reluctance that Jaime has
to being the Blue Beetle because the
alien Scarab has attached itself to his
back and it doesn't look exactly comfy
after an awesome shot of the second Blue
Beetle head chords flying vehicle the
bug in action with the word animal spray
painted across the front we get to my
single favorite moment of the trailer
where the wise Uncle Rudy imparts some
invaluable inspiration to our hero you
are our superhero for those in the
viewing audience who may be of a lighter
complexion and may not know what the
word gabron means allow me to introduce
you to one of the most versatile words
in any human language roughly
translating to male goat but here used
with Mexican love in a more colloquial
usage closer to the word gaboron
has been sorely lacking from any and all
superhero media and we're elated to
finally get to it in a major trailer
you're the Blue Beetle that could use
that Arsenal right about now ah you
never ask hell yeah foreign
[Music]
thought you'd never ask moment and
getting to see more of the nanotech
looking Sonic weapons that Blue Beetle
is using to dish out some pain on the
cord equipped bad guys we get a stinger
that drives home the point brought up
earlier in the trailer that Jaime Reyes
strength comes from his family because
we see Nana wielding some sort of
futuristic Gatling gun I have to quote
my friend Augustine Rios who said after
seeing this moment that's a hell of an
upgrade from the chancla that moment
also solidified that we're all bringing
our abuelas to see this movie and they
are going to lose their minds hey that's
all we've got for this Blue Beetle
trailer breakdown but tell us did we
miss any details hit us up in the
comments below and tell us how excited
you are to watch the movie with your
abuela in theaters on August 18th don't
forget to subscribe to all three of our
channels new rockstars the break room
and the Deep dive and support us by
having some merch at nerdriot.shop
follow me over at Heroes reforged follow
new rock stars thanks so much for
watching bye
foreign